[Music]
well there's a new push to solve the
biggest art heist in history of Boston
Museum has doubled its reward to ten
million dollars until the end of this
year now thieves made off with 13
masterpieces from the Isabella Stewart
Gardner Museum 27 years ago the stolen
artwork is valued at more than 500
million dollars Seth Doane visited an
investigator in the Netherlands who's
described as the Indiana Jones of the
art world to learn his theory about
where the art is today 27 years later
it's still a mystery thieves targeted
some of the highest value art from
Boston's Isabella Stewart Gardner Museum
leaving behind empty frames a tied-up
security guard and few clues major art
theft in Boston overnight two thieves
posing as police officers overpowered
museum guards the 13 stolen masterpieces
valued at around half a billion dollars
included a Rembrandt and a Vermeer I'm
100% sure that they are an island under
potential no doubt in my mind they
smashed a few was an audacious claim to
make after nearly three decades but art
investigator Arthur brand alleges his
leads point to the Irish Republican Army
we are focusing on the IRA we have had
talks with former members of the IRA and
after a few Guinness after few talks you
can see in their eyes that they know
more how do we believe you well I have a
track record we have found some pieces
back before so let's give this a shot
brands highest profile find to date came
working with German police to recover
bronze horse statues which stood in
front of Adolf Hitler's grand
Chancellery building he also helped
recover Salvador Dali's adolescents
how is this stolen art used they use it
as payment for drug deals for arm deals
sometimes they use it for like art
napping they kidnap paintings and they
use it as to get a lesser sentence to
find pieces on the black market brand
claims to have brokered deals with
terrorist groups the Mafia and a slew of
shady characters one hand you have the
police insurance companies collectors
and on the other hand you have the
criminals the art thieves and the forest
so there are these are two different
kind of worlds and they do not
communicate so I put myself in the
middle this was all decently he helped
recover this art which had been stolen
from a museum in his native Holland for
the Netherlands and especially for the
town of Horan these paintings are the
history this one is even worse
Ronald Diaw who is restoring the damaged
worse so to see it like this now is
quite a change
yeah first so yeah I'm very happy with
it the paintings had been stolen in 2005
from the West freeze Museum in the
quaint town of corn
eleven years later thanks to leads that
brand followed to Ukraine five of the 24
pieces were returned with great fanfare
out here dig is now the museum director
they stole a catalog of 17th century
Dutch masks and you've left these empty
frames is a reminder and as protests why
a protest art crime well there isn't
anyone dead okay it's its art so many
people don't take it too serious but
brand says folks should Interpol ranks
art crime as the fourth highest-grossing
criminal trade when you steal Rembrandt
or van Gogh this is natural
international cultural heritage it
belongs to you to me to the viewers the
Gardner Museum is offering that 10
million dollar reward and welcomes any
efforts to get this stolen work back but
when we asked about brands leads they
told us they're not new we've covered
them years ago the museum is skeptical
Museum says your laser are dead ends yes
but what well we see if it's a dead end
navigating this underworld requires
patience a bit of luck and a fair share
of bravado I've heard you say I don't
care about the reward money they can buy
me a beer yeah I have a hard time
believing that this on some levels but
money it's about Fame it's about
something more no but it's the offender
and it's the fame if you solve these
Arbella Stewart Gardner theft after 27
years what more can do
it's an irresistible challenge for what
so far has been an unsolvable mystery
for CBS this morning
I'm Seth Doane in the Netherlands I say
nothing wrong with a little reward money
- no very nice in one of the great
mysteries in
in ours I mean one of the great museums
by the way your favorite apparently I'd
always love visiting it and it's part of
the drama seeing those missing paintings
the frames up there and now looks like
you when you go next time Jeff you'll
have something else look at maybe so